The Joe Rogan experience.
I was thrown off Airbnb. This is a fact you did not support me on this.
Did you did not. You said, ah, he should have done the dishes.
This was your dishes, Joe, but you shouldn't have been thrown off of Airbnb.
Okay. Well that shouldn't leave dirty dishes.
So we pay a $450 cleaning fee. Oh,
Airbnb. 400 fee. They do the scam. Now they call it COVID cleaning,
which is fake because regular cleaning and COVID cleaning are the same thing.
Cleaning is cleaning. You're not going in there with hazmat plates.
What do you mean? What, why didn't you just clean the plate?
Because this is a vacation. Are you supposed to clean the plates?
I don't know what the rules are, but I don't like the service.
If that's the case, I want to feel like you should be able to leave.
Not a fight. If I pay $450 for a cleaning fee, you should.
And the thing is there were two lesbian women.
And I mentioned that and that's why I was kicked off Airbnb because they thought
they were Elizabeth and they had a horribly designed house and they should have
maybe as a gay guy or someone to fix it. But as a gay guy would have you done,
what would you have done rather to fix it? Well, all the furniture will,
you couldn't sit in. It was like art pieces. All of the furniture was like,
it was like a little, you couldn't sit in or Tony Hinchcliffe, hood incident,
Tony Hinchcliffe is a bird. He can perch on things.
I'm a human human, I'm an American human.
We can't sit on a leather cow, high chair.
It's an RP like this is it. Wasn't the piece. It was like,
it was a chair of like sticks with like leather collided with these weird
stools. You take pictures of these. I took all the photos. I put them on.
My Instagram was like, these are, these are not for human beings.
These are for like lesbians to drink tea and perch and whatever.
But like I lesbian. So why do you,
why do you care about their sexual orientation? That's why you're going to get,
cause they're insufferable. They were inseparable.
They wore little hats and had a dog little hats.
They had little weird hats and they had a dog. Do you like big hats,
but like dogs? I, not that they had like a weird Weimer Reiner.
I just knew who they were. I knew who they,
I could see the photo and what I knew.
And they probably saw my photo when I hate that fat conservative or whatever,
even though I'm really in the middle politically and even weight-wise,
but in this state,
but they got mad at me and they got me off Airbnb because I
discussed this on my podcast in a colorful manner. And I quote unquote,
threatened, burn her house down as a job. I'm not having your house back.
It's a bit, I'm not going to burn your house out. But I said like,
watch your back. Who knows what happens? It's a joke.
But these women don't get jokes and it's not my fault, but like to, to,
to give me a horrible review and they find out that you talked about them online
on your show, it's a decent size show. So I think, yeah. Yeah. It's big.
I mean it's w w okay, you, you guys win,
but it's big enough where if we say something on it, it, it got back to them.
One of their minions told them, and they were, uh, first of all,
they asked me to give them a good review,
which you're not allowed to do in the Airbnb process.
Right before I wrote the review that I've never given anyone a bad review on
Airbnb. I don't do it. I'm not a rag review. They texted me and said, Hey,
our cleaning lady came, had a stroke, LOL, but just give us a good review.
And I'm like, she said, oh, well, yeah. I was like,
I don't know why she had a stroke.
Cause it's literally dishes has your cleaning lady not encountered dishes
before.
Uh, if like they took black light and scan the walls.
There's nothing,
I haven't left them a tartar sauce and said use it because we didn't use it.
So you predict, I mean, look at that. I like it.
These oh, golf course. Of course you do.
This is meant to do.
Iowasca. Is.
That a fireplace? Which you can't use because they're not insured for it.
What does that square hole? It was his fireplace that you can't. It's weird,
dude. It's a fireplace. It's like chest level. It's a cold environment.
Is that a.
Weird, I mean, aren't fireplaces supposed to be on the ground floor.
Like, why is this? Is that really a house? It's really a fireplace. I mean,
they're culturally appropriating native America.
It's just the whole thing makes American. You don't know. They are not.
I know because I've seen them, but what about Elizabeth Warren?
That's a good point. But I was in a weird place. It's weird.
The whole house is weird. The house is weird. And I just left.
There was a few dishes in the sink. Show me that picture again. And then,
and the review of me was like, this guy was, are horrible gas. They said,
I broke a cactus, which is literally impossible. You can break cactuses.
How we're crunching the spikes when my hands were on ecstasy. Yeah. I mean,
these, these, these, I don't understand what.
I'm looking at. Correct. So there's like a.
Log night, 1200 a night. I got it for to stay there. Oh no,
I really would. It's absolutely repulsive. I would.
Sit in those chairs and.
Joshua, Joshua tree is a litter box for drug addicts.
No, it's for people like to do mushrooms.
Get, grow up and get a real drug problem. Take a Percocet at your office.
Okay. Not everything has to be attorney to hyperspace, not everything,
but some things. Sure. I just am a fan of pill, heads and coconuts.
I like people that are productive, but you're in Joshua tree.
That's the place where psychedelic Rico.
And I used to do acid and go to a bar like a person. I didn't,
I didn't have to, if I would be a subprime mortgage guy, I would do acid.
And I would cross off, like, if I did DMT, I would go.
And when you meet the aliens and they give you all the information about how the
world is, I would have tried to sell them condos. You know,
I would have brought them into my world. I like it.
Relaxation happens here. I bet it.
Does. Yeah. Washing dishes. That sounds like the.
Bars on the chair, the.
Square.
Like sitting on that. The, where I wouldn't know where to put my hands.
I'd probably put them below those.
Metal boxes. Really look at that.
Lady. I like how she said, wait, go back to the pool was cold.
You go back to that picture. That lady's hot. I like that.
This is well there. Fatphobia she's naked. Yeah. This is what they do here.
They're obsessed with human beings. Is that a big deserve.
Apartment? It's hard to tell because it's in black and white, but she's hot.
I like her. She's just reading. She's like, even though I'm hot,
I just want to educate myself.
That's a really realistic.
He hasn't it in months. That's realistic. I shredded.
And he's hanging out with a super hot girlfriend. There's a.
Few dishes.
Tim, Dylan. I want to buy this house. This is a great place he.
To stop. I like it. Yeah.
That was a high five. That's a high five.
Yeah. It's a high fidelity. It was not conducive to having fun at all. I.
Was running around killing people. That was.
The. I didn't say anything bad about it. You could see the.
Cactus and the coyotes.
Oh, this is not good. I love it. I loved it so much. And move states.
I would listen. I could look at it. I mean, come on.
That's that's that's we're starting again.
Talking to the wrong guy. I know. I know. I love the chairs. Well,
listen, I don't look at that. Look at that chair.
I don't believe in Baxter chairs because I have good posture. We get high set.
I left four dishes and these people treated, treated me.
didn't you just clean those four dishes. And when they close,
I'm paying a massive cleaning fee. This is.
This is money. No.
No, no, no, no. You have to pay it. It's free. You have to you're forced.
Is that the cactus? You broke? No, that's a cactus. It was broke.
When I walked in, was it broke? It was because somebody was probably,
I don't know, shoving their. It was broke when I walked in the most epic.
Way you've ever seen that.
Is that really, is that the most?
I've never seen. I've been to some nice houses. That's not true.
I like that espresso machine though.
A lot of.
This house. I liked this house.
I like this house a lot. It's all fine. The women were out of control.
And again, if you look at my review, I said, nice things. I.
Think I've always said nice days on two lesbians.
I've always said nice things. And they just said to me, like,
I was a horrible gas. If you look at their review of me,
they said it was a horrible gas. Why were you horrible? Well, they said,
I left the house in disarray and I broke the cactus and whatever.
And nobody broke anything.
Oh, you should do well, you can't do it anymore because he's not Airbnb anymore.
But you should just make a video of you leaving the house and then no one can
say. Wow.
I'd like to get back on Airbnb because I made them, I did.
I spent money on there and that's where I would go and use to travel and not to
hotels. I would do Airbnb, especially move you when you have an opener.
And yet people, I know people at a whole podcast, get some nice. Yeah.
That's much better. Nice food. So I'd like to go back on Airbnb,
but we'll see what happens. That's okay.
Is there an avenue for reconciliation? I.
Don't believe.
So. These ladies, whoever you are, ladies, Tim's a good guy. And I'm your fan.
I'm a fan of you. I like what you did with that place. I like it.
I like the chairs with no backs to them. I like it. I like the weird chairs.
I like your view. I like your house. Look at that.
You could sit out there by the pool and watch the guy with a ripped abs and his
girlfriend.
This is like, this is like a fi a FEMA tent.
[Inaudible] not.
That's not [inaudible]. And then lizards and scorpions, the whole.
It's a nice little pool to beautiful view. Look, those people are enjoying it.
Why can't you enjoy it without.
The real, those people.
The hot guy in his hot girlfriend. They're real. They're not.
Real. They don't exist at the Ana.
Gym. They're right down.
They hired these people. These are not American elitist.
I speak for Americans, but I live here. I know, but that doesn't matter.
I speak for Americans who make hot dogs and sometimes leave the plates of the
thing. Cause we're paying a $450 cleaning fee.
And I just think that we should be able to,
you should be able to come in and clean it. You know what I mean?
You love the house so much. You clean it ladies. So anyway,
I'd like to get back on there, but I won't,
I won't be allowed and that's okay too, because maybe.
They will let you.
Back on. I would imagine not. I violated some safety protocol.
Uh.
Protocols, the safety one, which one is the same?
The one where you can't threaten to burn down people's homes.
I spoke to my lawyer. He said to just leave it alone. My lawyer was like,
just leave it alone. He goes, I don't know what you're doing. I'm like,
I'm going to a high octane war with a few desert lesbians.
There's two desert dikes that are gunning for me. And I'm going to keep,
I'm going to ride this till the wheels go off. And my lawyer's like, Hey man,
what are you doing? So.
What am I doing? I'm boosting up my podcasts.
I'm I'm trying to fight the good.
Fight paid. That's just tell him how do you think I get a good point?
No. So, I mean, I didn't involve Alex Jones. Could've chose not don't do that.
I'm kidding. That's nuclear nuclear.
Option. That's a nuclear option. Yeah.
Because he'll find some reasons.
The Airbnb didn't exist.
Let's say that connection to the globalists Satanists or something.
Catch new episodes of the Joe Rogan experience for free. Only on Spotify.
Watch back catalog J R E videos on Spotify,
including clips easily seamlessly switch between video
and audio experience on Spotify.
You can listen to the JRE in the background while using other apps and can
download episodes to save on data costs. All for free.
Spotify is absolutely free.
You don't have to have a premium account to watch new JRE episodes.
You just need to search for the JRE on your Spotify app.
Go to Spotify now to get this full episode of the Joe Rogan expenses.